hello to all the fans in China I'm sure
you already know that Marvel Studios
thor ragnarok is confirmed and will be
released in China don't forget to watch
Thor Ragnarok when it comes to a cinema
near you
so I sense a great change in your future
destiny has dire plans for you my friend
I have diet plans for destiny
hello the goddess of death is invaded as
Joslyn I thought you'd be glad to see me
as god is dead
it'll be reborn in my image
neither stopper here to prevent Ragnarok
the end of everything
so putting together team
you'll date
[Music]
surprise this will be such fun
I
he's a fighter
I'm not a career
and goddess of death
[Music]
what were you the god of again
[Music]
no idea in this film we wanted to kind
of strip it back and wanted have more
fun with it you know I'm tyka had the
exact same idea and we were both saying
dance for Ragnarok it's trying to have
more attitude ragnaroks sort of a new
cycle from the light of the world and
all the realms of the universe it's the
destruction of the old' and the rebirth
of the new Nets really exciting to me
surprise this would be such fun the way
that I've approached this is to rebuild
it in a new way look great dude totally
I think it's just perfect mix for where
the character and story need to go you
know different costumes different
weapons different cast or characters to
work or give you a different energy Thor
has been a crisis he never went back to
Asgard to claim the throne he wanted
adventure when we pick him up he's at
the end of this search for himself
we're the ones we survive district I'd
say the odds
million to fund
you know I wanted to take people on a
ride and and pincette some comedy into
it and adventure that keeps people
laughing along the way but also as
inspector call them the stuff that gets
people excited he's a fighter
you
you